and kids are always like my mom's not  putting me on my dad's not letting me do  my thing and I'm like you're entitled  you're 22 you're walking into a business  that's been alive for 15 years your mom  and dad have all these other employees  that put the bricks down to [ __ ] make  this place and just because you won the  [ __ ] sperm game you think you earned  something shut the [ __ ] up and work for  a decade my dad doesn't listen my dad  didn't listen to a single thing I was  thinking I did [ __ ] and when he was like  that wine isn't selling and I saw and I  sold all 19 cases miraculously my dad  started to listen the number one thing I  ask kids I'm like well what have you  done well he won't let me do anything  I'm like you are copping the [ __ ] out